breaking news we are all over it broke
the news broke at 10 30 10 48 i saw i
said hey we got to talk about this in 12
minutes on the show and so the us
treasury has announced brand new
sanctions against a crypto exchange for
its alleged role in laundering ransoms
for cyber attacks now lauren feiner i
think is how you pronounce it from cnbc
amazing amazing amazing reporter
basically what this is doing is it's
marking the first time that an action
like this has been taken against a
virtual currency exchange
and it comes after a string of a bunch
of cyber attacks uh across industries
and the treasury has said that the
ransomware payments totaled more than
400 million dollars in 2020 alone more
than four times that of 2019. so
obviously anytime that you put
ransomware cyber attack a big number on
it 400 million dollars in a single year
people start to say oh we got to do
something understood the ransomware
according to this article is a type of
cyber attack where actors often shut
down access to key programs and demand
payment usually in a cryptocurrency like
bitcoin to unlock them now part of what
is so interesting about this is there's
a fascination in the mainstream press
with the idea of bitcoin being used as
part of the ransomware the cyber attacks
but as we know bitcoin has a public
ledger it is fully transparent and you
can see all the transactions on it so
it's not exactly the best thing to do is
if i call up john and i say hey john
i've hacked your computer you should
send me bitcoin well if john sends me
the bitcoin what's gonna happen is that
there is going to be recorded forever in
an immutable database publicly available
and auditable by anybody in the world a
transaction where john pays me bitcoin
in exchange for that now when that
transaction is there people may not know
exactly why that transaction's there
they may not know who owns the wallet
sending or who owns the wallet that is
receiving but it is recorded in history
forever in an immutable way that anyone
can audit so down the road if all of a
sudden we figure out that john kept sent
ransomware to a wallet and so did
somebody else install it to somebody
else and then we could start to identify
wait this wall is somebody who's doing
nefarious activity and then all of a
sudden i go to withdraw the bitcoin
let's say the fiat or i try to move it
into a different exchange and i happen
to have done kycaml on that exchange or
there's some other connectivity point
then it can be identified hey that was a
bad actor here's who they are and then
the law enforcement the regulators etc
they can step in they can uh actually
act we even saw during one of the
ransomware attacks if you remember a
couple weeks ago where people requested
bitcoin that bitcoin was given to them
the regulators and the law enforcement
were able to actually see on the
blockchain where the money was being
traced they continued to trace it and at
some point the bitcoin was sent to a
centralized exchange account and when it
was sent there immediately they were hit
with a
order to freeze the bitcoin do not allow
that bitcoin to leave your centralized
exchange and the law enforcement is able
to step in and kind of the whole thing
unwound from there so
my point in that is yes it has happened
but people are very quickly waking up to
the fact that you probably don't want to
get paid
in a digital currency that has a
transparent ledger because it actually
makes it in some cases easier to track
you down if you're a bad person than if
you were to use something else so the
treasury department's office of foreign
assets control will designate the
cryptocurrency exchange called suex i
believe i i don't know this exchange so
uh this is new to me suex for allegedly
playing a role in facilitating financial
transactions for ransomware actors
and the article goes on to say while the
treasury emphasized that most virtual
currency activity is legal
key point
while the treasury emphasized that most
virtual currency activity is legal
really important here bad actors exist
in every single industry i can show you
a ton of people laundering money in the
legacy system doesn't mean that everyone
the legacy system's bad same thing here
there's bad people doing bad things
doesn't mean that all of it is bad as
the treasury says most virtual currency
activity is legal the technologies
facilitating those payments can be
exploited by bad actors true
cryptocurrency transactions are
decentralized can be harder to trace
than those conducted through traditional
financial institutions probably false
the department said that in suex's case
it helped facilitate illegal activity
for their own illicit gains end quote
now i do want to talk about this last
piece here which is while the treasury
emphasized that most virtual currency
activity is legal technologies
facilitating those payments can be
exploited by bad actors of course we
know that to be true of everything guess
what criminals money launders drug
dealers murderers they all use cell
phones nobody's trying to ban cell
phones but the technology mostly used by
people for legal purposes some bad
people use cell phones same thing here
same thing with the dollar same thing
with everything did you know criminals
use cars we probably should look at cars
right did you know that criminals wear
shoes we should look at no of course not
nobody's claiming that right so most of
the activity is legal but there are some
people who use the active uh use the
technology for illegal purposes of
course but this next cent is really
important cryptocurrency transactions
are decentralized and can be harder to
trace than those conducted through
traditional financial institutions i
personally don't necessarily agree with
that i actually think that because they
are decentralized and they use a public
ledger they are easier to trace the
transactions than let's say in the
legacy system right what i do believe
that maybe this is getting at is the
fact that it is harder to tie the
recipient or the sender to an actual
human identity because all you see is
the wallet addresses so there's a
difference between being able to see the
actual transaction and trace where the
money flows through a system versus the
ability to go to a bank and say who owns
this account and the bank immediately
has already done kyc aml and can just
tell you remember what we talked about
with the open c situation is people
random people on the internet were able
to look at the flow of funds identify a
wallet and then quickly understand hey
this person works at the company they're
buying these things before they're
public maybe we shouldn't allow that to
happen or maybe we should but let's flag
that issue you wouldn't be able to do
that in the legacy system so i think
there's more transparency here um and
which for the purposes of this if you
want to put yourself in the perspective
of law enforcement trying to catch bad
people doing bad things it actually
should make your job easier than let's
say the legacy system you can imagine if
they were using physical cash it would
be nearly impossible to do this but
it also brings up the fact that there's
privacy issues so what happens if all of
a sudden john and i are both good actors
and we just want to send bitcoin back
and forth to each other how much
surveillance should be allowed in the
system or how much surveillance should
there be in the system do we have a
right
to financial privacy right why should i
have to give up my information if i'm
not doing anything wrong should we
actually have more surveillance on
everybody to catch the small percentage
of people who are doing bad things or
should we not impede on the financial
privacy and freedoms of every individual
just because we're pursuing a couple of
people there's some very very big
philosophical questions in here there's
a lot of legal complexity here there's
regulation law enforcement uh and tons
and tons of lobbying going on etc so
this is a really complex issue but to
see the treasury come out and take
action like this
i think most people again most people
agree that if someone is doing something
bad that should not be encouraged that
should not be allowed of course if
you're doing illegal things they are
going to come after you whether you like
it or not that's just how the rules work
if you break the law they're going to
come after you if if you don't break the
law then you're probably okay for the
most part but john what do you think
about this
yeah this makes a lot of sense right if
a bank was doing this probably the same
sanctions would be passed down that's
right so if someone was doing an illegal
activity and they knew about it and kind
of let it go because they were getting a
financial gain from that they would
obviously be sanctioned and um
reprimanded for that so i don't see
anything wrong with them doing it i've
never heard of this exchange before um
so it seems relatively small but in the
grand scheme of things i think it just
lets people know that this
this industry is being watched um and
it's actually more helpful to law
enforcement and to people trying to
catch those bad actors and anything else
people want their money through big
banks all the time i mean the big bit
how many times have the big banks gotten
in trouble for laundering money for drug
cartels the mafia criminals they
probably do it more than in these
exchanges
i don't want to go down that uh that
road but there's a lot of banks who uh
who know what they're doing but uh the
banks have a uh a catch-all a safety net
and most uh i wrote about this one time
that actually what banks can do is banks
can identify suspicious transactions
that kind of sort of look smell and act
like money laundering but the bank
doesn't step in and say oh please don't
do that anymore oh we refuse your
business what the bank does is the bank
simply flags it to this organization
africa the name of the organization and
says hey this is a suspicious
transaction and then what they do is
they do that for you know hundreds
thousands millions of transactions per
month and then somebody has to go sift
through all of these suspicious
transactions and so if ever there is a
situation would say oh you know x person
was laundering money in the uh bank the
bank statement says well we flagged the
transaction like we didn't know what it
was we did our best we we flagged it and
so if you just flag as much as possible
one it makes it harder to actually
figure out which what is good and what
is bad so that shutting down customers
but then two is you basically just say
hey well we flagged it we flat like you
know we can just claim uh that you know
it's on you you have to look at it yeah
we did our job we noticed something
suspicious we reported it versus the
bank coming in and saying hey you can't
do this now i will say the banks are
very good at finding out who runs crypto
businesses and who's trying to do things
in crypto and shutting those accounts
down they they are amazing at doing that
let me tell you how many times i've
gotten a call from a founder who
literally says pomp i need help i go
what's up and they say the bank just
shut down our account right and then i
gotta go scramble and help them try to
figure out a bank that will actually
bank them and so it's not to say that
they don't have the capabilities it's
not to say that they can't do this stuff
it just happens to be that sometimes it
is selective when they try to do it but
it's estimated uh that over two trillion
dollars a year is laundered and used for
illicit purposes in the fiat system
which is about the size of the entire
crypto market so when we talk about it
on an aggregate dollar basis it's much
much higher in the uh in the legacy
system and most people say oh that's
because the crypto market is so much
smaller there is a report out from the
former i think he's the cia director his
name is uh mike morrell if i remember
correctly and he estimates that about
point four percent less than half a
percent um and i think there's another
company that also came out the report
that i think says less than half a
percent of all transactions in bitcoin
are used for illicit purposes or
nefarious purposes so on a percentage
basis that's much smaller as well than
let's say the fiat system so i think
again when you have a transparent public
ledger it drastically reduces the uh
excitement that people have of using
these assets for illicit purpose what's
up guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today if
we're gonna be the best business show we
obviously need the best partner that's
why the exclusive sponsor the best
business show is sofi they're an
all-in-one platform that allows you to
invest in all kinds of different assets
including stocks etfs crypto ipos and
they even have an automated investing
function if that's your thing so before
we start getting after it again make
sure that you go download sofi you get
an invest account and when you make your
first crypto trade regardless of what
you buy they'll give you 10 in bitcoin
for free it's that simple head on over
to sofi.com to get started today thanks
so much for watching and i hope you come
back and watch more the best business
show tomorrow
[Music]